Here in my garage just bought this new Lamborghini here,
but you know what I like more than Lamborghini's knowledge did
and webinar Wednesday guys,
welcome to a segment of the show where we get scammed.
So you don't have to in the past, when talking about gurus,
I've talked about their marketing. I've done that stuff.
I've traditionally strayed away from going into their course.
Partly because I don't want to spend $2,000 also,
partly because it's hard to show that because it's behind a pay wall by I
decided I would do it anyways.
And we're going to have to find a way to just summarize this for you and try to
get the idea to you without actually showing the content.
And our first guru is the grand Pappy of all gurus.
The guy who had the brilliant idea to pretend he knows something on YouTube,
get a bunch of poor, broke, desperate people to pay him a lot of money,
and then try to leverage that into an actual legitimate business.
I think Ty Lopez is now trying to like buy real businesses.
We'll see how that goes.
But he got his real start with this whole internet marketer thing.
I'm like this genius guru who knows the secret of health, wealth, and happiness.
You guys all know the app.
Here in my garage just bought this a new Lamborghini here, but you know what?
I like a lot more than materialistic things, knowledge.
But today we're going to be dissecting what happens behind the chorus,
behind the pay wall. So bring down the screen
always feels like that's going to hit me. Okay guys, 67 steps to success.
This is a, what he kicked it off with.
I believe you guys are gonna tell me if I'm wrong there,
but we're going to be going through a few things. Okay? When reviewing this,
we're going to talk about the price. We're going to talk about what I like,
what I don't like. Should you buy this course? The full review,
all that stuff now to start with the price, uh,
67 bucks is what I found at four with a $67 renewal.
If you don't cancel, cancel,
I think that's probably pretty mid range to low range.
I think that's like sort of more of a trip wire product was trying to get you in
the Ty Lopez funnel system. And indeed a lot during the course,
you're hearing him talk about the upsells. If you're part of this closing group,
if you're part of this mastermind, you should buy this upsell.
And he always says, Oh, I don't actually want the money. No, no, no, no.
I don't want the money guys. I do it for you. So you pay attention.
You're not going to pay attention to less unless you open up that wallet, baby.
So that's the price now onto the course itself.
The first thing you should know about this course by Mr. Perez is that it's
very, very, very long it's 50 hours long,
which if you're looking for value might seem like a good thing,
but unfortunately 50 hours does not mean 50 hours of good
content. It means 50 hours of Tai Lopez. Basically.
Bloviating about little anecdotes in his life. I mean,
nothing of this felt prepared.
It felt like he just had three points and his goal was to hit like a 30 minute
marker or like an hour long marker. The amount of just kind of like, um, uh,
what, where was I going with? This is ridiculous. Luckily I, you,
I was gonna feel bad and watch the full 50 hours,
but Ty Lopez made me feel better.
And this might be the only takeaway that I got from his course was during the
speed reading portion. Now we all know Ty Lopez. He's the King of reading.
Write one book a day. Well,
actually it turns out he doesn't read one book a day. He does something.
He likes to call speed skims a book a day,
which might mean reading it for five minutes, reading it for 10 minutes,
15 minutes now, but basically anything but read it all the way through.
Uh, and this is his rationale behind it. I want to get away from stories.
Stories are what, how authors fill up the pages of a book. So, you know.
Yeah, that's exactly what Tyler has did in this course.
They're just trying to sell their book. They don't want to sell,
most authors could write a 10 page book with everything.
They know the cliff notes,
but they don't want to do that because they can't charge you 20 bucks for it.
Yeah. The irony here is palpable.
And that's when I realized I'm not going to sit through all of this, uh,
Ty Lopez justifying a $67 course instead,
I'll just get like the main high-level points,
because really it boils down to an each lesson he's got 67 lessons.
It comes down to like one thing or like maybe one or two ideas. Uh,
and this is where we come to,
I guess the good thing and the bad thing of the course now,
what do I like about Ty Lopez? He encourages reading.
I'm never going to hate on a guy that encourages reading baby.
It's the best mechanism to self-improvement.
It's what I tell you guys to keep doing. I probably don't say it enough.
If you have a library card, you don't need any of these idiots. Right?
What I'm trying to tell you, you can get way deeper ideas.
You can improve the quality of your thinking,
the clarity of your thinking all for an incredibly low price.
So I like that about him.
Hopefully he encourages people to read even his book list.
I have no problem with. I thought his booklet is pretty good.
Read a lot of the books on there and I would wholeheartedly endorse a lot of
them now, what do I not like? Well, this whole course,
and this would be sort of,
this is getting into like the really rating part of it.
The whole course is reheated self-help Tai Lopez speed,
read the Barnes and noble self-help section and put it into 50 hours of content.
Okay. 50 hours of him just telling little stories about a grandpa,
Joel Salitan or whatever, which by the way, is this man a farmer or isn't he,
I recently saw a video where he's approaching a horse from behind.
How did I not know this?
But we're supposed to believe he's a farmer. Cause he's got a hat on.
Like I'm not even a farmer. And even I know that. Look, can I be a farmer too?
Now that I got, I put a straw hat on, this is ridiculous. But anyways,
that's the biggest problem is that if you've read self-help,
if you've cracked open three, four, five books from the self-help section,
you already know all this stuff and you have it from the source material where
people have spent years crafting together, like the,
of decades of experience, right into one or two really crystallized ideas.
Or you can have a guy who read it for 15 minutes at the breakfast table,
regurgitate it to you over an hour. I mean,
I think the difference is clear.
And this is like where the value proposition becomes kind of weak is that really
he's just regurgitating ideas all the while saying that you should read.
But if you read then the value of Tai Lopez's course basically goes to zero. Uh,
and if you just listen to summaries,
then you're kind of doing what Tai Lopez is saying not to do,
which is to be a dilettante.
Another incredibly ironic part of this course is he talks a lot about how you
need to drink deeply from the well of knowledge.
But Ty Lopez seems very interested in not drinking deeply from the well of
knowledge instead of drinking very widely from the well of knowledge.
I don't know don't become a Dilla taunt.
And now the next thing I want to talk about is listening to dilettantes.
See dilettantes are usually the loudest.
Oh, by the way, if you guys don't know a ton is a fancy way of saying amateur,
someone who's just read very, just skim the surface. Um,
and Ty Lopez, his literal approach to reading is speed skimming.
So his message is don't listen to dilettantes.
Don't be a dilettante, uh, which I agree a lot with.
But the problem is is that Ty Lopez is a dilatory telling you not to listen to
dilettantes once again, I don't know how you get away from the irony here.
I would also say here,
as an aside on the reading proposition is that this idea he calls it strip
mining, like you're mining for gold.
You only want the gold only look for the gold in the book.
And as soon as you get it, you like put the book down.
You don't care about that book anymore.
I think it applies to like a certain class of business book, but honestly,
most self-help isn't about getting as many ideas into your head as possible,
which I think is what he does. He like conflates,
just reading a lot of ideas with being really smart. But in actuality,
it's internalizing those ideas and applying them to your life.
That is the only thing that matters,
which is why a lot of people can watch hundreds of high class performers share
their biggest ideas and they never become a high class performer themselves is
because you can take an ideas without actually getting out of it.
What they're actually saying, you're not actually internalizing the ideas.
And I think strip mining is the absolute way to make this mistake is by not
really spending time in the idea of like, literally just like, Oh my gosh,
what's this, this is what his idea of speed's giving is. Oh,
look through the book up, got that book. It's gone. That's the idea.
It's a little dumb. I think there's a time for reading broadly,
but eventually if, if what I'm getting actually what he's saying,
like you should actually read deeply didn't that's not how you do it.
So it felt a little confused there. Now,
if you find any of this ironic, uh, you're not the only one.
And I think the best way I can explain it is that you could actually learn a lot
from Ty Lopez. I'm not joking by watching what he does,
not what he tells you to do. So I think if you watch his, his, uh, original ad,
you know, here in my garage,
you could learn an amazing amount about sales and marketing from that,
right from that, if you actually read like Ty Lopez reads,
because even though he obviously schemes a lot of books, he is well read.
I think you'd be fine. I think you do well.
I think the problem is is that what Tai Lopez does and what he says to
do are two different things, which leads to a very interesting thing.
When you're watching him tell you his life advice, because you're kind of like,
Oh, wait, didn't you do that to us. Oh wait,
did aren't you using these tricks on us? Like take, for example,
his part where he's saying don't be the sucker in the room while talking to a
bunch of people who bought some reheated set of ideas that were from a bunch of
people that they should have just read instead of watch Tai Lopez's course.
What beyond you just consciously going,
I'm not going to be the sucker in the room. Right?
You make that conscious decision. It doesn't mean you won't be the sucker.
Like I can't explain to you how funny this is to me that he's saying this,
but okay. Let's keep going.
Conscious changes are well, like Freud said,
the mind is like a iceberg.
90% of it is below the water in your subconscious.
So the Lollapalooza effect now.
He's really jumping around here.
What he's quoting now is a Charlie Munger thing, Lollapalooza effect, basically,
it's the idea that cognitive biases stack on top of each other, uh,
to produce a much greater result, small biases can stack on top of each other.
And he's going to basically say, don't do it.
Don't avoid Lollapalooza effect.
Okay. Oh, well there's a lot in the ultimate closing system,
sales green belt stuff. And you might not be in that.
If you're in an entrepreneurial,
definitely should check that out because have best thing you always lose at an
auction. Think of what happens to you. You walk into an auction,
there's a person on stage
stack is of the authority bias. So automatically even subconsciously,
they are perceived by your subconscious as an authority because they're
literally physically above you. Then they're doing things like going once,
going twice, they're creating scarcity and urgency. Like, Ooh,
if I don't buy this right now, I'm going to lose it.
Even though it's something you've lived your whole life perfectly well with, uh,
you know, perfectly well before you even heard of it,
it's still an influence on all these things added together.
Create what Charlie Munger has coined the Lollapalooza effect.
And the Lollapalooza effect is a forest too powerful,
a coalescing of multiple biases
all at once.
And that is why they say they don't even put themselves in that
situation. It's not something you can build up willpower around.
Okay? So all of that to say, he's saying, look,
don't get around things that prey on multi of your cognitive biases,
cause you don't have enough willpower to withstand it. It's just,
you're going to lose every time. This is what a webinar is.
Guidance is what Tai Lopez's ads do is they're
Lollapalooza, Wonderland, it's scarcity, it's appeal to social proof. It's like,
look at all the testimonials. It's all of these, Oh,
it's prerecorded live webinars, guys. This is all for you.
I did this just for you. They're professional marketers. That's what they do.
And so Ty Lopez in a class that you got sold to with the lollipops who's effect
is saying, don't fall for this effect. So again,
we're left thinking, okay, Thai, what is this? It's like a course for suckers.
How not to get it suckered in the first lesson is what you've already been
suckered.
So you're a sucker it's like bizarre to watch this and watch him say like,
Oh yeah, you should try to avoid these situations at possible.
Ty Lopez is webinars and all these marketers webinars are the thing that he's
talking about. And not only that,
he's also simultaneously saying that you're the sucker in the room. So yeah,
that's how I felt this whole entire course rich with like sort of
irony. And though he had some good ideas that like I agree with and I've,
Kernelized myself, they're all from books, right?
They're all from books that most people,
if you just go through the basic reading list of a self-help section,
you're going to learn are the basics of a business book section you're going to
learn.
And this guy is basically projecting himself to be the authority on all these
topics. Despite reading just very broadly on all of them. And then he says,
don't listen to dilettantes. So I don't know, take from that.
What you will all in all rating, let's get to a rating.
I think you guys get the picture. Uh,
I would go ahead and give this out of five stars. Uh, 1.5,
I would say, you know,
the marketing was over-hyped if you thought this was going to lead to a good
life really quick, obviously it does not.
So it doesn't fulfill its side of the marketing.
It's just a bunch of like common sense frameworks that most people would know.
I think the person who should buy this, though, I'm going to give you,
somebody should buy this. If you like Ty Lopez, uh,
and you realize the marketing's misleading and you've never read the self-help
section before and you want a broad swath of it regurgitated through
some long-winded rant, right? Uh,
maybe you have a lot of listening you need to be doing and you can't stand the
voice of anyone by Ty Lopez. This might be a good course for you. You know,
if you want to avoid the source material and just listen to Ty Lopez,
this may be a good course for you, but.
For the rest, the rest of you.
Yeah. I would say, save your money, get a library card and be, well,
I think that's going to about do it.
Thanks for coming to this episode of webinars Wednesday.
Tell me if you liked it, tell me if you hated it.
Tell me if you want to see more, who do you want to see next week on webinar,
Wednesday, where we get scammed.
So you don't have to let me know in the comments below and as always,
I'll see you tomorrow.